[Musique]
et vous lui avez parlé quand pour la
dernière fois ça fait quelques semaines
grand mère maman elle m'a appelé il ya
quelques semaines je crois qu'elle avait
peur elle avait l'impression que
quelqu'un voulait rentrer chez elle
et
dt tu te souviens tu étais maman
j'imagine que je suis sorti c'est quoi
ça elle était dans la propriété quand
tes grands parents en ont hérité
apparemment il n'avait pas toute sa tête
tu vas pas la mettre à l'asile quand
même elle peut plus vivre tout seul
maintenant ça elle a besoin d'être
surveillés
tout va bien grand mère voyez que c'est
par là qu'il était montré qu'ils celui
qui rentrait dans la maison
maman qu'est ce qu'il ya il est là il
est sous mon lit n'y a rien ce tour
l'imam vérifie pour moi
[Musique]
je suis là pour t'aider
je te vois tu sais
[Musique]
cette maison nous semble étrangère